are two hulks enough hulks for the MCU
we sure hope not there are plenty more
hulks to pull from the pages of Marvel
Comics
yeah he's red instead of green but
there's a bigger twist in the comics the
Red Hulk is revealed to be Thaddeus
Thunderbolt Ross Oaks arguably worse and
definitely most dedicated human
antagonist General Ross is a military
man who can usually be found heading
whatever Armed Forces organization is
trying to contain the Hulk so the news
that his obsession led to his own spin
on hulking out was surprising to say the
least as red Hulk he retained Ross's
martial skills making him an extra
dangerous adversary his power set also
differed somewhat from his green
counterpart Bruce Banner's Hulk powers
up when he gets angry but red Hulk
starts radiating heat while still being
extremely strong of course he also has
energy absorption power so he could
surely be a powerful adversary for
virtually anyone in the MCU sadly the
actor who portrayed Ross in the MCU
William Hurt passed away in 2022 however
the character remains somewhat integral
to the Hulk Mythos that's especially
true since in the comics Ross is hulked
up by the leader who's set to return in
the MCU and Captain America New World
Order and Modoc who will join the MCU
and amp man in the WASP quantumania so
Marvel Studios will have to figure out
whether they should give the Red Hulk
powers to another character or risk
navigating the Waters of recasting Ross
regardless of how they'll go about it
Red Hulk joining the MCU wouldn't be a
massive shock especially since in the
comics he has been a member of the
Thunderbolts
in the event that red Hulk isn't
available there is always Red She-Hulk
the Hulk identity of Betty Ross Bruce
Banner's love interest and Thunderbolt
Ross's daughter as read She-Hulk she had
a complicated relationship with both men
teaming up with and betraying both in
various circumstances but he also has
another gamma-powered identity that
recently reappeared in the recent
Immortal Hulk series a bird-like
creature that dates back to the 1970s
though Marvel Studios men want to avoid
the name Harpy the MCU version of Betty
was played by Liv Tyler in 2008's The
Incredible Hulk never forgive what
you've done to him he's a fugitive you
made him a fugitive since that film
Tyler has stayed busy on TV shows
including the leftovers at Astra and
many others if the MCU finds a way to
bring her back Tyler would no doubt
prove to be a great asset if it takes
Hulk powers to do that so be it
Amadeus chose Hulk journey is very
different from that of Bruce Banner he's
already an established Super Genius
crime fighter by the time he becomes a
Hulk which he does voluntarily by
absorbing some of Polk's excess
radiation Joe's initial control over his
Hulk is also considerably better than
banners to the point that he dubs
himself the totally awesome Hulk of
course Hulk always wins in the end and
Joe eventually encounters plenty of
trouble with self-control show would be
an interesting addition in the MCU both
as a character in his own right and as
an example of yet another path to
becoming a Hulk he's also a pretty
light-hearted character which would fit
in pretty well with the mcu's recent
lean toward Hulk themed comedy it
probably won't be the very next hole to
make his MCU debut but it wouldn't be
all that surprising if his name was
already somewhere on that brainstorming
whiteboard Kevin has I possess the most
advanced entertainment algorithm in the
world
in the comics there are a lot of
different hulks residing in Bruce
Banner's head and many have come out
physically at one time or another in the
MCU there have only been two real
distinct personalities the smashy
original and now smart Hulk you're Hulk
again Smirnoff
yeah I didn't come up with it otherwise
the Hulk in the movies has had more of a
gradual Evolution and looking
personality but there's one Comics Hulk
Persona who it would be great to see on
film Joe fix it one of the Hulk's
incarnations that's gray instead of
green don't fix it is smart but not in a
professor type way he's more Street
Smart he's a straight up mob type dude
and has been known to wear neat
pinstripe suits and wheeled tommy guns
when he's not actively hulking out a
mobster hole just has a lot of story
potential just imagine his interactions
with She-Hulk Thor or the Guardians of
the Galaxy as an added bonus The
Immortal Hulk Comics reveal that Joe fix
it can also surface in Bruce Banner's
body instead of physically becoming a
Hulk imagine Mark Ruffalo acting tough
while chewing a toothpick and wearing a
fedora thank you
there are lots of Hulk like and Hulk
adjacent characters we're leaving out
here because they either weren't created
by radiation hulkling is a crease scroll
hybrid or they have gamma Powers but
aren't technically hulks like Doc Samson
and Sasquatch but there's one more key
player in Hulk's story who's yet to make
an appearance in the MCU it was also a
Hulk for a brief while though his story
goes far beyond that in the comics Rick
Jones was a kid Bruce Banner saved from
the gamma bomb explosion thus exposing
himself to the blast and becoming the
Hulk ever since Rick has been a jack of
all trades apart from being a notable
supporting character in various Hulk
Comics he's acted as a sidekick for
numerous prominent superheroes including
Captain America and Captain Marvel he
also gained various superpowers of his
own on more than one occasion though he
hasn't physically appeared in the MCU
yet Jones's existence was hinted at in
The Incredible Hulk if he were to turn
up with Hulk powers after all these
years it could very well get Bruce
Banner his own Captain America the
Winter Soldier moment introducing a Hulk
version of Rick Jones and giving him a
Bucky barn style MCU Arc would not only
be a handy way to introduce this giant
missing piece of Hulk's comic book
stories but it would also be a fun nod
to his Comics background when he was
Captain America's sidekick he actually
took on the name Bucky
[Music]